foreign
live from the headquarters of Ramsey
Solutions broadcasting from the PODS
moving in storage Studio this is the
Ramsey show where we help people win in
their life specifically their money
their relationships and their work I'm
Ken Coleman I'm joined by fellow Ramsay
personality my esteemed colleague George
Campbell it is always good to be with
you I threw in the esteem today I've
never felt more esteemed well we haven't
been on together in a while due to our
busy life schedule so it's always good
to be in the in the studio with uh the
one and the only George Campbell energy
is palpable it's palpable the phone
number is triple eight eight two five
five two two five that's triple eight
eight two five five two two five George
is ready I'm ready and I think Sammy
might be ready in Orlando Florida Sammy
how can we help
hey guys how y'all doing we are having a
blast already what's going on
love to hear it hey um I'm just calling
to ask advice on what I should do
regarding wanting to start a business
um I currently work at a hotel I fold
laundry and I do room service making 13
an hour
and um I am 17 going to my senior year
next year
and I just wanted some advice on how to
go about that and how to introduce it to
my family yeah tell me about the
business
of the business um it's a great on
demand business run through Etsy using
an AI image generator to make the
designs so you basically tell the AI
what you want to create it creates it
for you you sell those designs on Etsy
um and make the profit because there's
no production costs have you tested this
yes I have and how's it going
oh it's good I
um I started okay well last week I
actually uploaded products and started
making I haven't made any sales but I
have gotten a lot of visits I think so
far 76 visits to my website
so how much money everybody else
has it sold anything yet okay so what a
week into this test real fresh
yeah yeah very fresh yeah and so it's
interesting uh you said how do I tell my
family or how do I talk to my family
about it which leads me to believe that
you're nervous about something or maybe
even fearful is this true
yeah definitely um it's just that my
parents never went to college so it's
like when they were raising us they were
really strong on getting good grades
um doing well in school so you can go to
college to work a 95 a safe job and
honestly I just don't feel like that's
the route for me if that makes sense I
understand that but I think we need to
separate you trying this Etsy business
from this big giant conversation about
your path in life
yeah and separate the two so are you
still in high school
yeah yeah um I just I just finished
junior year okay good so you've got
another year of high school to begin to
uh to think about how you're going to
have this conversation with Mom and Dad
and and and and and I'm going to give
you some thoughts on that but this idea
of just telling Mom and Dad that I've
launched at Etsy business I don't is
there any tension there just telling
them hey I started doing this we're
trying it
I've mentioned it to them and I did tell
them that I started uploading products
but I could tell they were a little iffy
about it and um like it wasn't really
like they weren't really happy I guess
what was their objection
if any oh
um they didn't say anything specifically
but it's just the way they responded to
it they didn't seem like
um there was like that like that good of
an idea I guess you could say well first
of all that stinks and it hurts right
yeah let's just be honest anytime we
tell our parents something I mean I'm
I'm in my 40s and if my mom and dad are
going don't get excited about something
I feel a little tinged there you know
and truthfully they probably don't fully
understand it I think that's and that's
kind of the like tilt head question mark
they understand if you go to an office
job and you have a title they can tell
their friends about it's harder to go oh
he has he has an Etsy have you heard of
etsy he's got an Etsy shop and he does
these t-shirts it's harder to explain
and it doesn't make them look as good
yeah and so that part I wouldn't get
hung up on yeah I think you ought to
spend more time trying to figure out how
to get more traffic and then George you
actually have some background with this
uh I'm I'm just I'm putting you on the
spot because you can handle it George
but he's had 76 visits to the site
that's not a lot
and he hasn't sold anything yet what's
he looking for because you've done
digital marketing you've been a marketer
and you've also got some technology
Savvy what do you think well number one
you're reliant on Etsy and the way the
Etsy game is played is it's kind of a
pay to play to show up in the top
rankings so here's what's going to
happen Sammy there's going to be a lot
of competition in the AI space now
you're not the only guy out there who's
had the creative idea to do AI print on
demand I think it's a great idea let me
just put that out there you could
probably do really well with it but
you've got to have a long-term game plan
of what happens when there's 30
000 people who are also doing print on
demand who have more money and resources
and talent and time than you so yeah
pursue it but I wouldn't go putting my
eggs in the basket until I go I have a
for six months straight I've increased
my revenue and this is enough for me to
actually create a profitable business
long term yeah Sammy my advice on this
is and George is right so taking
George's advice your mindset needs to be
I'm going to pursue this to learn from
it not pursue it to get rich from it and
that's going to change your expectations
just learn everything you can learn
there's no risk here you've already
outlined that if you've got a good head
on your shoulders now let me transition
very quickly to having this very big and
important conversation with Mom and Dad
over the next year because you're you're
a rising senior
um Mom and Dad's want the best for their
kids and when Mom and Dad are afraid
that the choices their kids are making
aren't the best ones that's when they
have the highest objection you
understand that don't you see me yeah
definitely okay so telling Mom and Dad
this is what I'm doing
deal with it and I'm not suggesting
you're going to go that route
but even just laying it out that way
even with the sweetest of tone they're
they're going to get really fearful and
so my advice to young people uh in this
situation where you go I don't think
college is for me let's go find out for
sure if College
is not a necessary path so two questions
for you that you need to answer for
yourself before we talk to Mom is is
college the only way to do what I think
I want to do is it the best way if the
answers clearly no then we've got some
real anecdotal evidence we could sit
down with Mom and Dad and we're very
thoughtful and they can see you've done
your homework and you show them an
alternate path so for instance if you
want to get into coding and you go hey
Mom and Dad I can go to a coding school
for twenty thousand and be done in nine
months uh or or whatever versus go to a
school that I can't afford and they
begin to see oh Sammy's got a clear path
it makes sense it's got a nice
trajectory for him financially long term
and he's figured out an alternate way
besides a college degree to get there
and it's a proven way George now all of
a sudden I think Mom and Dad are like
okay this isn't some big scary you've
presented us yeah when you actually go
I'm creating a great income from this
and I don't have any college debt to
show for it with some useless degree I
think they're going to respect you even
if they don't approve of the path and
it's not what they would have done
that's okay but I think you coming at
this respectfully going I don't want to
waste a lot of time and money pursuing
this I'm going to get an education in a
different way I want a pursue
entrepreneurship they may have some
ideas and go great let's get you a
business degree just to get another
another notch in the belt yeah I think
parents support George is commensurate
to how clear your plan is and they can
see aha this is doable and they mean the
best so don't let them get you down
they're actually trying to protect you
he's George Campbell I'm Ken Coleman
this is the Ramsay show your calls we're
right around the corner
[Music]
foreign
hey Dr John deloney here I'm a huge fan
of both meditation and prayer and good
mental health includes slowing down
gaining control of your thoughts and
plugging into something bigger than you
and Halo makes it easy to start a daily
practice of meditation prayer and
finding peace Hollow is the number one
Bible app in the world and you can
tailor content towards your faith
tradition from scripture readings and
prayers to meditation and journaling
hallow makes it easy to practice prayer
meditate and build a deeper more
meaningful spiritual life and ReDiscover
true peace go to hollow.com Ramsay today
to get three months of hallow for free
that's hollow.com Ramsay
thank you
foreign
[Music]
welcome back America you are listening
to the Ramsey show where we are here for
you it's your show America we're
answering your questions so that you can
win in your money in your relationships
and your work all three of those areas
of our life are tied together if you're
losing in one of those areas it is going
to impact the other it's just a simple
fact I'm Ken Coleman joined by George
camel we are here for you this hour the
phone number is toll-free jump in at
triple eight eight two five five two two
five that's triple eight eight two five
five two two five I wanna go to you
George here because I saw you did this
uh you did a little poll uh
on on the gram on the gram and here was
the question for the poll I love it I
said if you're a credit card user what
is the biggest thing holding you back
from getting rid of the cards all right
that's how I posed the question I got
tons of responses how many people
responded to you uh a few hundred at
least all right so this is anecdotally
this is science basically this yes
that's right and I got a lot of the
natural responses that we've gotten for
30 years right it's the points the cash
back the rewards I love getting my free
flight I need it to to book hotels and
rent cars and I got to keep up my credit
score so I can get a house and get car
loans and all these things but the one
that shocked me Ken uh-huh a lot of
people said fear fear of
just fear that's why I dug in I did I
dm'd I said tell me more about that
elaborate yes because that means a lot
of things to a lot of people some people
did admit they said hey this is a safety
blanket it's a crutch I if something
goes wrong I know I'm covered with my
line of credit thanks to 28 interest
from the credit card company so what a
blessing right but I wanted you to
address this idea of fear because you've
been leading a financial peace class
virtually and this has come up a lot
yeah when it comes to the thousand
dollar emergency fund scares me I can't
cut up the card because what if what if
what if right there's so much fear and
some of it stems from their childhood
they told me hey I grew up poor we grew
up not having money oh we grew up or if
one paycheck didn't show up we were
screwed yeah and so I have a lot of
empathy for those that have that fear
but you've talked a lot about this on
your show whether it's career or money
fear is holding people back in a whole
lot of ways yeah well a couple things on
that most of the time if you actually
look at the data the things that we
worry about which is another placeholder
for fear you know because I think fear
is defined as I'm worried that something
bad is going to happen I just think
that's the way I define fear and I think
that's really true and so most of the
time the things we worry about rarely
happen so let's just that's just some
basic psychology study right there where
they like the things we worry about most
of the time never actually happen so
there's that the second thing is is that
people are afraid
that they're going to be destitute
broke so far behind the eight ball that
they never recovered that they forget
that the credit card is going to hit
them for 28 percent versus and let's
give you a real life example let's say
an HVAC system goes out okay because
this is one of the things that popped up
on our FPU class
I've got an old HVAC system I'm gonna
have to replace it it's on its last leg
I don't want to be in the house all
summer in sweltering heat not be able to
sleep and by the way I get all that I
don't minimize any of that it's like
yeah I get it all right so they think
the credit card then is the safety net
so if we have to put eight grand into an
HVAC system or six grand or whatever it
is
well we put it on the credit card no
problem but now we're paying 28 interest
as opposed to going the HVAC company and
going hey here's my situation here's my
financials I need this HVAC system we're
we're stuck so we either are with
ceiling fans and you know and just fans
or whatever we're gonna or we've or
replaces let's say it's in the winter
time and you go to the HVAC company and
go listen
I can cash flow this
and I will cash flow it you know and
just having a human conversation with
somebody yeah but just relying on the
credit card puts you in more stress and
more problems because while you take
care of the immediate need
you're stuck with it for a long time and
so I think it depends George on the
specific fear uh but a lot of people
just feel like I'm not going to be able
to be comfortable and take care of my
life and uh Les who was on with me or
one of our FPU coaches we talked about
AC going in my car one time it went and
this is when we first lived here in
Nashville the first time and we were
working the baby steps
and I couldn't afford I could have but I
didn't want to stop the momentum so
George I got up earlier and drove into
the office an hour earlier
so that I wasn't sweating profusely to
get into the office that's okay at the
end of the day it didn't matter I was
going home
and then one day I was driving home
George
and insult to injury I came up to a
stoplight and was almost like uh the
debt gods were trying to embarrass me I
got no AC I'm sweating hair all over the
place because the windows are down
and that I don't know what you call that
your roof liner inside the car just all
of a sudden detached out of nowhere and
it was sitting on top of my head I felt
it at a stoplight I look up and this way
and you know how embarrassing that is
yeah because you think that everyone at
the stoplight is going look at this
loser over there it's a hundred degrees
in Nashville he's got the roof interior
carpet hanging on his head I went home
was so mad I got the staple gun out of
the uh out of the storage
that's therapeutic right there two
Staples in the top took care of that
problem and cost me nothing wow well
what are you afraid of yeah you afraid
of being embarrassed at the stoplight I
get it that's a good question is you
know a lot of people like to they're
very optimistic when it comes to their
own stupidity they're they're going yeah
we're gonna open the card will be great
they're very optimistic when it comes to
justifying their spending habits their
decisions and very pessimistic when it
comes to following a proven plan where
they go yeah having a thousand bucks is
scary and you should be scared and the
problem is when you have the credit card
still there you have a false sense of
security yes you have a false sense of
comfort and the book The Comfort crisis
you guys have been talking about this a
lot with Dave I think we're too
comfortable I think part of the reason
America is where it is today yeah broke
in debt anxious miserable stressed is
because we're aiming for comfort and
convenience and the easiest path the
path of least resistance the most
convenient path instead of going dang it
I really got to work that extra job to
get out of debt even faster and that's
what I love about baby step one I don't
love that you're scared to death but I
love that it puts a fire under you to go
I wasn't safe ever I had the illusion of
safety that's right and then once you
have the emergency fund and baby step
three you got out of debt you don't need
the credit card like but you don't
understand that mentality of what if
because I don't think that they've been
taught this so I think this is like I
want to tee you up to teach on this
let's say that the thing happens we've
got a thousand dollars in baby step one
but then a seven or eight or ten
thousand dollar or even a 1500 expense
like oh it's not enough Ken yeah but my
point is they're all worried about this
big thing above and beyond a thousand
dollars yeah what do you teach what
would you tell them if you're sitting
one-on-one with them and go okay this is
seven eight thousand you only got a
thousand what are their options well
number one we say pause the baby steps
right if you've got kind of a storm and
in that case we're gonna we're gonna pay
all the minimums on the debt so we're
gonna cover the basic bills everything
else all the luxuries throughout the
window right now because we gotta sell
everything we can work as much as we can
to find that Gap to make that margin
once you've got that expense covered or
back on track we're attacking the debt
and in most situations uh I've seen they
end up not needing the full thousand or
they pause it and they end up cash
flowing it and make sure you have the
right Insurance in place this is
something we teach because most
emergencies you know Health Emergency
you're going to have up to your
deductible and then you're covered right
and your auto insurance make sure you've
got the right coverage there these kinds
of things help me sleep at night to make
sure that I'm covered in case of
something crazy happening but a lot of
times it's psychological and it's them
justifying why they want to keep the
card around Georgina the old phrase
where there's a will there's a way in
other words it means you know if I'm
willing to figure it out I'll find a way
do you poke holes in that when it comes
to this very scenario or do you believe
that that holds true I'll find a way to
not use a credit card I'll find a way to
pay it off I'll find a way but I'm not
going to use a credit card for an
emergency well when you take debt off
the table if you just in your mind
pretend and go credit cards are not an
option debt is not an option what would
I do if this was the 1930s and debt
wasn't marketed as heavily as it is
today what would I do you'd go all right
I'm gonna go sell some stuff I'm gonna
go get the side job I'm gonna cut down
all my expenses to Bare Bones I'm going
to work out a plan a payment plan with
the HVAC guy to pay this thing off and
we're going to figure it out
so my challenge to everyone out there is
could you live 90 days without using
your credit card put it in ice in the
freezer lock it up somewhere stick to a
debit card in cash and for 90 days and
DM me if you're going to do this
challenge I want to report back 90 days
from now and see how it changes you
financially spiritually emotionally if
it gets you further down the line to
where you want to be financially wow I
love that George it's a good challenge
at George Campbell on the ground right
there with a K don't wear it out and if
you're over the age of 50 that means
Instagram thank you for that caveat
there you go all right hey uh we gotta
take a quick break but I mean it is
quick and when we come back more of your
calls they're lining up this is the
Ramsay show
[Music]
we've been doing business at Ramsey for
more than 30 years by now we're a
well-oiled machine but it wasn't always
that way yes we've always had a vision
always had determination and a drive to
help people but what we didn't have was
one central place to access all our
numbers so that we could get further
ahead or quickly see when we needed to
Pivot we were always jumping back and
forth between different systems and
spreadsheets so when netsuite by Oracle
helped us Wrangle our Revenue inventory
expenses and more into one place here's
a game changer and netsuite's number one
Cloud Financial system can help your
business gain the same visibility
because businesses thrive on timely data
and netsuite's real-time analytics can
help your business have immediate access
to your numbers daily so you always know
where you stand and you can move quickly
so go to netsuite.com Ramsey today 8 and
set up a free product tour that's
netsuite.com Ramsey
[Music]
the Ramsey Show continues I'm Ken
Coleman joined by George Campbell the
phone number to jump in this hour is
triple eight eight two five five two two
five that's triple eight eight two five
five two two five paying off dead is
smart saving and investing is smart but
there's another key to winning with
money that a lot of people Overlook and
that is protecting your finances from
emergencies
and that's where insurance comes into
play George you love you some insurance
I really do I don't know why it's
fascinating to me yeah you've always
really been good at this content and uh
and so there's 10 kinds of insurance
coverage George that I know you know uh
that you might need and we've got out of
two it feels like thousands so we've
really curated the only ones you need to
think about you always make me laugh if
I ever need a good laugh I could just
walk over to your desk
and I could say George tell me about a
ridiculous insurance coverage and you
would say falling coconut Insurance
that's real that's a real Insurance do I
want to buy it yeah do I need it no I
just want to be able to tell my friends
yeah hey get that falling coconut
Insurance yeah this is a real problem in
some countries Ken it really is it's not
making the headlines it would be a great
lead-in to you announcing to your
friends and family you were going on a
Caribbean vacation maybe you guys have
fallen coconut insurance for the Bermuda
trip yeah yeah want to make sure
everybody's prepared you don't need that
one well you don't need that one but
we've got you covered
um the coverage checkup is is a great
tool that we've built for you and it's
going to tell you the types you need to
add drop or adjust we even rank your
coverage by importance email it to you
and connect you with a Ramsay trusted
insurance provider so that
you can make the changes or the
additions that you need and this only
takes about five minutes one of our
users wrote in his name is Donald he
goes uh for anyone who has not completed
this checkup do it now you never know
when something will happen and you never
want to leave your family in a bad
situation we agree Donald so go to
ramseysolutions.com checkup that's
ramseysolutions.com checkup final word
on that George uh I was just thinking
about some calls we took last week that
were real sad because people didn't have
the right Insurance in place medical
Auto not the right liability coverage
all those things matter so double check
it today absolutely all right let's go
to David who joins us now in Dallas
Texas David how can we help
hey you can't hit George thanks for
taking my call you bet I have a question
with some of the excess income that I
have so
um just for some background I'm uh just
about 27 years old
um and I'm through all the baby steps
through step four I should say no debt
I've got about ten thousand dollars and
a savings account that's essentially my
emergency fund and um in terms of other
Investments that I have i max out my
retirement uh max out in HSA I'm
actually at a stock purchasing program
through my employer you guys don't
necessarily like that but we'll get to
that a little bit later
um and so uh after all of those uh
allocations
um I take home roughly forty six hundred
dollars a month and when you take out
expenses uh I expect to be left with
something around forty four thousand
dollars for the year that I um I just
don't really have anything and so that I
necessarily need to do with it
um I'm single don't have kids I don't
have a house so I pay rent that rents
about 1200 bucks a month and so I'm just
curious uh what you guys's opinion is
about what I should do with that Surplus
did you say your take-home pay was 4400
yeah it's about yeah 4 600 a month but
then you said you have excess
essentially 3 600 a month
how does that work if your rent alone is
1200.
the numbers just weren't adding up for
me
the I have 4 600 a month that I take
home
um after all those deductions that I
just mentioned and then rent is about oh
sorry I should mention too that I have
about eight thousand dollars that I get
in income
um from Investments uh that I've made so
it's really about uh 3 600 that I get
from work
um uh from that 4 600 and then for the
year I get another eight thousand
dollars so that's not just from your
income okay correct so do you are you a
homeowner currently is that a goal for
you
I'm not a homeowner currently I would
say that a home is probably not in the
picture for at least another uh three
years okay why is that is that a job
lifestyle
lifestyle more than anything else
um I like where I live I live around a
lot of friends and family
um and uh specifically in the section
that I live in homes are fairly
expensive and uh I just I like the
situation I'm in right now okay well my
next goal for you if you're walking
through the baby steps you don't have
kids your single would be to pay off a
home early and it's a great part of your
wealth building journey and so I'd
recommend you're in a great spot to be
able to do that sooner rather than later
and if you've seen home prices three
years ago versus today A lot of people
are going goodness gracious if I had the
money I wish I bought three years ago so
that's my only concern for you is that
home prices are a moving Target in three
years from now especially in your area
they're going to be astronomically more
expensive
but outside of that you just get to live
give and uh you know if you want to
upgrade the car you want to increase the
emergency fund you're doing all the
right things you've got this savings and
investing muscle down I want to see you
Flex it more in the giving and spending
side my guess is you don't spend a whole
lot of money
foreign
maybe a little more than you would
expect I definitely enjoy uh going to
sporting events and doing some traveling
so there is some income there anything
that happens there but uh it's not
hugely it doesn't put a big dent
um in My overall uh income good well I
would set some goals right now with your
goal list and if just the goal is
investing for the future that's fine you
can park it in some index funds if
you've got a home purchase down the line
but I would want to put it down on a
house sooner rather than later for sure
yeah thanks for the call David all right
let's go to Los Angeles next John is
there John how can we help
hey gentlemen how's it going oh we're
having a blast John what what can we do
for you
hey um so I'm on babysat 3 my wife and I
um on 30 she's 27.
um we're we just paid off a hundred
thousand dollars in debt and
um yeah
um so we're aiming to have our three
months by September nice but really just
you know after the pandemic trying to
have vision for our life longer term
I wanted to ask you know for the early
baby stop baby step adopters what do you
suggest to do as a gap fund
um for those who want to semi-retire in
their early 50s or mid 50s since you
can't take out of a 401k until 59 and a
half
good question okay so we'll call that
work optional where you get to choose
what you do how much you work uh versus
I got to keep this job because I need
the money
correct yeah yeah well so I would max
out all retirement options first which
would be you know your 401ks IRAs hsas
all of that stuff and beyond that what
people use in order to do that is called
the taxable brokerage account so this is
just money outside of retirement that
you invest and let's say you're 50 and
you're not going to be able to tap into
the 401K till 59 and a half you've got
to have enough money in that account to
tide you over for nine and a half years
and that's very dependent on your your
goals your lifestyle your expenses all
of that
so you've got about 20 years to plan
that out which is great yeah now let me
just tell you something John what do you
think you think you're just gonna not
work and all of a sudden have plenty to
do uh there are a lot of retirees that
are getting back into it because it
wasn't all that it was cracked up to be
so I love the strategy and it gives you
options my friend but as you get to that
age uh know that um you need to be very
very active and even with Hobbies you
might want to be doing something more
productive and just keep that in mind
we've got a lot of these these young
people and I'm not saying it's his
situation but you're familiar with this
this financially independent retire
early big movement and this is not John
Let's be very clear but a lot of them
are they're working crazy hours I mean
give them credit crazy work ethic but
they're working to try to make a certain
Nest Egg by 40 and never work again and
we're beginning to see some of the
leaders of that movement who have
already announced uh
they either get bored or go back to work
right and uh there's there's something
to that this idea of being productive
and doing something and I like how you
called it work optional what does that
look like what does that feel like but
I'd rather sink my teeth into something
I love for the next 20 years instead of
something I hate in order to retire
early yeah and here's what I want people
to understand we're all about investing
so you have options but I think
retirement as a I'm never gonna work
again is overrated there's a lot on
Netflix to catch up on Ken Financial
Peace is not overrated and options are
not and and our investment strategy is
going to get you there all right good
stuff all right don't move more of your
calls coming up this is the Ramsay show
[Music]
thank you
foreign
welcome back to the Ramsey Show I'm Ken
Coleman I'm joined by my colleague
George Campbell the phone number to jump
in on the conversations triple eight
eight two five five two two five we're
gonna talk about your money we'll talk
about your relationships and your work
because all of those are just very very
relevant to you having a peaceful and
successful life triple eight eight two
five five two two five Amarillo Texas is
where Manny joins us Manny how can we
help
hey guys thanks for taking my call but
I'm just really torn and kind of
stressed about the situation I'm in
um just to give you guys a little
background I just graduated college last
December I played football in college
had a pretty successful career there and
uh
Fort Hayes it's a D2 yeah in Hayes
Kansas
receiver nice all right George doesn't
understand any of that we just I'm
learning so I'm taking frivolous notes
but I find to be interesting and I'm
trying to bring him along when I can
anytime we can talk sports on the show
it's good for George it's a touchdown
yeah there you go yeah but uh I had a
pretty successful college career so I
gave him my best shot at the NFL ended
up talking to some Scouts and everything
and
um short short story basically didn't
end up making it didn't end up getting a
call so now I'm I'm back home I've been
applying to some jobs and now I'm kind
of torn between should I do
um a Commission job or should I do I've
applied to both
um jobs I've gotten a job offer in
Dallas commission
um financial advisor and I think I think
that would be awesome I think I would do
great at that but my parents don't know
if that's the greatest decision
um why I don't have
um just because the rent there is super
expensive
um and honestly I don't have
much money to my name right now
um
and but at the same time you know
there's no commissioned cab but there's
no there's no base and that's kind of
why they're they're really worried right
now and I got a job offer somewhere else
that's just 50 000 annually and um I
don't know if I should just take the 50
000 that way I know what I'm making or
if I should bet on myself
um my parents said they would help me
with the rent a few months but at the
same time you know I don't want them I'm
23 years old so I don't want them to be
yeah worrying about me you know I feel
like I should be worried about myself
well my colleague George Campbell is
there's no one better on the planet to
address this whole rent issue all right
so I'm gonna bring George in a second
but I'm going to focus in on what I
heard
and what I heard was option A
as you presented to us two job
opportunities option A is a job that you
described in detail and you described
with great excitement
and then you told us about Job B but I
know nothing about it other than it
offers you a fifty thousand dollar base
and so when I listen to that it makes it
very clear to me tell me if I'm wrong
that the job in Dallas that is in the
financial advising investing space
you're genuinely excited about it and
even though it's straight Commission
the athlete in you the competitor in you
you want to give that a shot and B
option b
literally when you think about it your
soul starts to seep out of one of your
ears that's the what I'm hearing is this
true or false
that is very true but the reason I feel
like that for option b is because
you know I can work there for 10 or 10
uh 10 years and then get a five thousand
dollar raise well it's still you know
like I'll never be financially stable if
I do look at that it doesn't matter what
your reason is the point is we have some
real enthusiasm and fire for option A
and if Mom and Dad uh uh are willing to
help you and you can swallow your pride
for a couple months uh until you figure
it out I'm open to that but this is
where I want to bring Georgia and George
I mean I get what Mom and Dad are saying
Dallas is expensive or certainly more
expensive than Amarillo but I think he's
got more options than he realizes where
he may not even have to tap mom and
dad's money for a couple of months yeah
so what would rent be for on your own
we're looking about fourteen fifteen
hundred dollars okay what about a two
bedroom where you get a roommate
uh I don't currently know anyone in
Dallas I've thought about that
um
yeah okay I think that's it we can
overcome that with mutual friends and
Facebook groups and all kinds of things
and good vetting you're not going to
have a crazy roommate but let's say you
had a great roommate and you got a two
bedroom for what 1600 1700
yeah probably about 17. great now your
rent is 8.50
and now we can reasonably even if we
don't make a hundred thousand dollars
the first year we're able to afford that
and could you work nights and evenings
while you get your book of business
going for your financial advising role
yeah yes sir and when when do they want
you to start
um second week in July
so how much money if we worked our tails
off could we make between now and moving
to Dallas where you've got yourself set
up for two to three months we're not
even asking mom and dad for money could
you do that
um yeah I could do that I mean it's
coming pretty quick maybe a few weeks
but I could I could probably gather up
some money for sure I'm just saying man
you're an athlete do you have any debt
yeah go work hard I got school for free
yeah amazing you got no debt let's get a
little pile of money for some moving
expenses and to you know get settled in
I'm telling you man George he can make a
thousand two thousand bucks between
Selling Stuff doing stuff working like
crazy at least I'm gonna challenge you
that uh to do that Manny here's the
other question I have that I want George
to hear uh on this money and budgeting
thing as you get started is this a true
straight commission gig or are they
going to give you some type of a very
small base or is it straight Commission
something that I really like is that
it's
you broke up is it straight Commission
it's straight commission okay and then
what are they telling you as what they
believe if you do things the way they
train you what do they think uh your
ramp up period looks like to where you
actually start making your first
commission what are they telling you
um a couple months until I make actual
money but um I projected first year is
94 so I don't know just like you said
the athlete in me just wants to go for
it and work my tail off you listen you
tried out for the NFL from a D2 football
program I understand
uh what kind of a leap that is I'm not
worried about you and I think you tell
Mom and Dad look I'm betting on myself
Mom and Dad I'm gonna be fine I'm not
gonna end up under a bridge and I think
George gave you some very good tactics
here George and I think I think if he
saves up some money he really works hard
to try to find a roommate or here's one
why don't you try to find a a an old
lady in Dallas who's got a room over a
garage
like Matt Damon in The Rainmaker I mean
this is possible I'm serious you can get
creative for sure if you want it badly
enough I'm the guy who moved across the
country with the hopes starting here at
Ramsey Solutions as an intern and
attempt and I I think you're going to
look back with a regret if you don't do
this that's exactly right so and keep in
mind we put a restraining order on
George for a while but it was a thing
after it was lifted he finally made it
here uh you know George this is I love
this thank you for the call uh Manny we
really believe in you and I think
there's a lot of Manny's out there right
there really are and and and I love
where again you just said look there is
a way to figure out how to not get the
nicest brand newest shiniest most
expensive apartment where all the
hipsters are at at the pool you know and
when I first moved here I was way out of
town I wasn't close to downtown
Nashville I had a roommate or two I got
my rent low my expenses were low I
wasn't going out to eat every weekend
you remember the numbers uh roughly yeah
I want to say when I first moved here it
was like 1200 bucks and so my rent was
uh it was an old friend from college
that had also a lot of times you're
gonna say an old fart the way it was an
old fart no I didn't live with an old
person I would I think it'd be great to
live with an elderly folk it would be
you wouldn't have to worry about noise
no they'd always go there before 9 30
after they're watching Murder She Wrote
I would watch Golden Girls reruns with
him I'm an old soul but there's a great
lesson there if Manny wants it badly
enough he's gonna figure it out and that
is absolutely what we're saying here and
uh what are your thoughts on Mom and Dad
you know we don't know the situation I
don't want to project too much on them
but again we were talking about fear
earlier in this hour mom and dad have a
healthy dose of fear when Manny goes I
want to go to Dallas and I want to do
this and it comes from a good place yeah
a lot of the times it's not toxic they
just want their kid to be successful
whether it's for their own reputation or
because no one wants to see their kid
fail yeah they don't want to see their
kids struggle yeah but I think them
letting him experience this whether he
fails or not is the healthiest thing
they can do I think that's true so good
all right young man thank you Manny
again for the call I love this and this
is a guy who went for it for the NFL
he's not worried about failing I'm not
I'm not getting in his way no physically
or career-wise good idea George hey uh
George Campbell good hour I want to
thank James the entire crew behind the
glass to keep us on the air I want to
thank you America this is your show this
is the Ramsay show
foreign
[Music]
hey it's Ken if you love the show and
want a deeper dive on your money Journey
we have a Weekly Newsletter that gives
you trending and helpful articles and
tips on following the Ramsey win go to
ramseysolutions.com today to sign up for
our newsletter again that's
ramsesolutions.com to sign up for our
Weekly Newsletter
[Music]
thank you
live from the headquarters of Ramsey
Solutions broadcasting from the PODS
moving and storage Studio this is the
Ramsey Show it's where we help people
win with their money their work and
their relationships I'm Ken Coleman
George Campbell joins me this hour it is
a free phone call for you to jump in and
that's what we do we coach you we
counsel you we cheer you on Triple eight
eight two five five two two five eight
eight two five
five two two five you ready to go George
are you game on like Donkey Kong you got
the uh you you you you yeah it just has
some Roots I got the green tea with
honey as well and uh so I'm ready to go
as well let's go to Megan in Des Moines
Iowa Megan how can we help
hi um
I think he might call you bet
about eighty thousand dollars in student
loan debt that's all of my debt
um and about about forty thousand
dollars of that is in private loans
one of my loans is twenty thousand
dollars so that's a lot of breaking down
but that loan is my smallest loan at
twenty thousand three hundred dollars my
concern is is that the interest rate
just went up again to
11.25 percent
I got an offer to yeah I got an offer to
refinance my private loans
and it would refinance it to a rate of
7.25 okay and I was just wondering I
know that interest rate isn't always the
end-all be-all of it but that's a huge
jump yeah wow so here's how we view
student loan refinancing now generally
we're not a fan of refinancing because
it kind of makes you feel like you did
something but student loan refinancing
can be a good move and I'll tell you the
parameter so check off these boxes as I
say them out loud right
number one it's free to make the change
no application fees origination charges
whatever fees they want to throw in
their no fees number two you've got to
keep a fixed rate or move from variable
to fix you said it's a fixed rate
currently
great another box check checked off
there then you've got to keep the same
term or shorten it
is that the case with this one
um yeah I'm not quite sure how long my
current one is but it would be going to
a five-year term okay then in that case
I would go through with it in order to
uh chop down some interest without
causing you any further Financial damage
here without and without losing any
gazelle intensity because you want to
pay this thing off really fast
yeah my I'm excited my if I have all my
numbers right I should have the twenty
thousand dollar ones paid off by the end
of this year love it and so I'm that was
part of it if it would still be worth it
if I'm going to be paying it off by the
end of 2023. yeah
I would absolutely do it then and you
can get quotes from other places too uh
you know maybe don't take just the first
offer you can go through some different
companies and see what they offer but
always make sure they're not charging
you anything you're keeping get going to
a fixed rate and that you get a shorter
term or the same term well thanks for
the call Megan Good Advice George let's
go now to Allentown Pennsylvania Connie
is waiting Connie how can we help
thank you for taking my call I am a 62
year old divorced
um single mom my daughter's 22 she just
graduated college
my um question is I owe 84 000 on a
mortgage my salary is 39 000. and
um I do have some 10 000 in a Roth and
uh a 401k
my
concern is and my reason I'm calling is
I'm terrified that I'm not going to be
able to retire and pay off my house at
my age I feel like I'm basically
starting over
um
yeah
I you know I work second jobs
um
I just don't know how to get ahead
and also my main question is do I
when I do work second jobs do I put that
money in savings or do I work on paying
off the mortgage that's my first
question George before we dive in on
this uh Connie I'm curious to know what
you're making what is your income in in
your main job and then what are you
bringing in in these second jobs give us
a snapshot
at 39
000. what do you do my full-time job I
am
Terry okay
all right and then what are you bringing
in from the second job so you know give
us an example
it varies
um yeah if
Care Home Health Care I've done I also
do some crafting where that's kind of
closer to Christmas I you know bring in
some extra money that way
um I I am looking at
um and I love your opinion on this
um I do QuickBooks at my job and I was
thinking of possibly doing that
part-time on my own like maybe picking
up I think you could do that full-time
and double your income I I yeah let me
give you an ex I was looking at this
today George uh Connie I was reading
this today before the show I was looking
at what is the current list of some of
the best paying part-time jobs and
bookkeeping
is one of them and in certain places now
again you got to kind of see what the
lay of the land is in Allentown but you
can make as much as forty dollars an
hour uh doing bookkeeping part-time
Connie that's good money yeah and George
is right you could transition into a
role like that because because there's
just so many opportunities for you right
now and that's why I wanted to start
here because George is going to walk you
through the answers to your questions
but I'd like to see you increase your
income
in in meaningful ways not like crafts
here and there but okay if I can work
stand under 10 to 15 hours a week and
let's say I'm in that 20 to 40 dollars
an hour range that's real money Connie
and George is going to teach you how to
use that so let's let's let's work on
that that QuickBook skill and you could
be able to take you could take several
other classes or courses that you can
cash flow that give you more opportunity
to do freelance work like that and
nobody cares how old you are by the way
right right right and you've got a lot
of transferable skills even as a
secretary you could do office management
you could be an executive assistant you
could do some of that virtually
part-time and so I would get creative
and get excited about what that could do
for you as far as savings and retirement
so to your question great do you have
any money saved for emergencies
currently
I do I do I have um well I have about 18
000 in savings ten thousand in a 401k
and 7 000 in a rod okay
so we've got a good start here what we
need to do is continue down the path of
investing for retirement so I would do
15 of your income regardless of what it
is add in all your side income any part
of your income 15 towards retirement
then on top of that I would start
chipping away at the house with
whatever's left right now may not be a
lot but if you double your income let's
have a goal for a few years from now we
have no mortgage payment and we've built
up a nice little Nest Egg so that we can
have a dignified retirement that's my
goal for Connie yeah and she can do it
fantastic love I love it I think we
should we connect her to one of our
financial coaches kind of helper I would
love to do that let's do that Connie
hang on the line we're going to take
care of you and get you with one of our
financial coaches that kind of pay for a
session we're going to pay for a session
and get you that jump start into what
George told you because there is a way
and you can do it you aren't too old
you've got plenty of time thank you so
much Connie hang on the line for the
rest of you don't move more Ramsey show
coming up
foreign
[Music]
here I'm a huge fan of both meditation
and prayer and good mental health
includes slowing down gaining control of
your thoughts and plugging into
something bigger than you and Halo makes
it easy to start a daily practice of
meditation prayer and finding peace
Hollow is the number one Bible app in
the world and you can tailor content
towards your faith tradition from
scripture readings and prayers to
meditation and journaling hallow makes
it easy to practice prayer meditate and
build a deeper more meaningful spiritual
life and ReDiscover true peace go to
hollow.com Ramsay today to get three
months of hallow for free that's
hallow.com Ramsay
[Music]
thank you
welcome back to the Ramsey Show I'm Ken
Coleman I'm joined by my colleague
George Campbell the phone number if you
want to jump in on the conversation is
triple eight eight two five five two two
five triple eight eight two five five
two two five Raleigh North Carolina is
where Peter Waits Peter how can we help
hey how are you guys doing today it's
good to be on I think you guys are both
really cool well let me tell you
something I first I have three teenagers
and they remind me all the time how
cringy I am so I'm going to hold on to
that the rest of the day thank you sir
George on the other hand is always cool
me means it's very rare that this
happens so thank you Peter how can we
help you you're welcome yeah so my wife
and I are on baby step two and we've
actually kind of had to pump the brakes
a little bit because we're having our
Second Son in about a month hey so we've
been able to save that's exciting I've
been able to save about yeah we've been
able to save about 3 000 extra dollars
in preparation for that man we were
hitting the ground running good paying
off stuff and we're like let's save up a
little bit but actually I just want to
make sure I'm on the right path here I'm
hoping by the end of next year we'll be
debt free fully money uh fully funded
emergency fund
um I'm getting about a 50 000 raise in
February wow that's amazing yeah what do
you currently I just wanted to know
currently 70 000 so it's going to be
bumped up to about 120. heck yeah Peter
let's go buddy let's just pause for a
moment what did you do to get that raise
that's fantastic
yeah so I'm actually a UPS driver no
kidding and yeah so from the third year
to the fourth year it's a pretty
substantial raise I'm so glad that we
asked and I'll tell you why because I
want people to hear that you can make
really good money wearing an all-brown
outfit some great thick brown socks and
driving a truck I mean that's a big deal
that's good work man good for you yeah
it's good hard work and it provides yeah
for my wife good for you myself and our
our two kids so I'm grateful good for
you all right keep going Peter
yeah so we're forty thousand in debt we
have student loans personal loans HVAC
loans credit cards and so my projection
is we will be debt free hopefully by
June of next year does that sound doable
you think or
they're a little house poor right now um
and we knew kind of we would be
um before we started the baby steps
um
it's a mortgage yep okay what's the
payment on that
so the mortgage is 1300 but um with
Escrow in there that's another 600 with
escrow rolled into it so it's about 19.
that's some serious escrow man
yeah we had to get flood insurance and
then homeowners insurance and then
property tax so it's about 90 our
mortgage about 1900 a month right now
okay and what's your take-home pay
currently yeah
um 5200 a month right now
all right and that's going to change
drastically so right now you're at 36
percent of your take-home pay going
towards that mortgage but once you hit
120 you're going to be right on target
so it's going to be tight but we know
that raises coming on the horizon and uh
you're still knocking out some debt
along the way and can you work extra
sure
oh yeah yeah we can I I basically work
as much as I possibly can um you know we
have an 18 month old as well right now
in the trenches pregnant so
I work basically as much as she's okay
Peter you asked us yeah you said is this
sound right you know can we pay it off
be debt free next June I think the
question is for you what did you base
that on how much money based on the
amount of debt you have and the amount
of money that you have said okay this is
we're going to be able to put on each
month the question is is it doable for
you is it doable or have you over
projected
no I think it's doable we were able to
save I mean leading up to this moment
we're able to save about an extra 1200
bucks a month
um with our lifestyle
um and then you know once the baby's
born we can put all that towards dead or
and then with that and then our
lifestyle is not going to change once we
get this pay raise we want to get debt
free and get that emergency you're going
to do it and here's the deal I
appreciate the question Peter the reason
I brought it back up is because
and George can speak to this too but
when Stacy and I went through our debt
free Journey stuff happened and you can
put it on paper which is what you should
do and you can project and you can be
disciplined and then stuff happens so if
something happens and it ends up being
August
that doesn't matter what matters more is
what you just said which is
our lifestyle isn't going to change once
I make more money we're committed to
being debt free and I think that's what
matters so yeah give yourself access but
also what I like to do set a little a
goal that scares me just a little bit
towards I don't know if we can make that
but we're going to try I love that and
then try to beat that as you get your
feet under you that's usually what
happens more often than not versus oh it
took us a month longer and if it does
yeah dude you're still debt free a month
later right Peter uh I'm gonna turn the
tables if it's okay with you George has
got his first child on the way yes Peter
give me all the advice Peter you're
about ready to have number two give
George one piece of advice about
parenting a newborn because he knows
nothing what would you tell George
um just enjoy it oh
honestly that's it man it's it a lot of
people told me it's gonna be really hard
but the love that you have for that baby
just kind of outweighs how tough it is
honestly beautifully sad Peter for the
win that's as good as advice as you'll
hear all day on the show I love that we
turn the tables George oh we should do
that more often I think our listeners
have a lot of wisdom to impart to us
it's absolutely true all right let's go
to New York City New York the Big Apple
John is there John how can we help
hey guys how you doing good what's going
on
I'm 24 years old uh I've managed to save
just under a hundred thousand dollars
wow I have zero debt
making now um nearly 130 Grand a year
wow John slow clap for you my friend
thank you appreciate it uh it's taking
some sacrifice but I'm basically I'm
just wondering if I do want to get my
first real estate property uh morning if
uh now's a now's a good time or if I
should wait or you know I hear so many
different things tell us about it give
George the details is this a primary
residence are you wanting to get into
real estate investing no so I still
luckily live at home I have no payments
on rent or anything which is why I've
been able to save so much
um okay I'm really not in a rush I mean
you know it would be nice to live on my
own but uh I do want to get it's my
first property this will be a investment
property okay so why not get yourself a
place
oh I think I would you know I don't know
I'm not uh I'm not in a rush to are you
living with your parents
I am yes well I'll tell you something
you're no loser okay everybody heard
your story oh yeah but I mean either
Mama's cooking is good or you're just
cheap or maybe a combo what's the story
it could be both yeah you're a numbers
guy you're looking at this guy another
thing is I'm not I'm not home all the
time uh I I make good money I work on
ships so I'm gone almost half the year
oh see okay
that makes total sense okay all right
yeah all right so you may not like my
advice but when it comes to buying real
estate property as an investment we only
recommend paying cash
got it and that sounds as insane as it
is because have you seen the world
they're even more insane and they're
broke and all the people out there on
Tick Tock they're telling you to put as
little down as possible and then rehab
it and then do the HELOC and take the
equity out and put it on another
property dude these people have dead up
to their eyeballs and they're freaked
out that actually do this stuff the ones
pitching it are making money from their
online course of course so what I would
tell you to do is if you're willing to
do that in New York City is that right
no I think it's too expensive here I'll
probably go somewhere else uh I like
Maine a lot it's cheaper up there
because the other side of this coin is
being a long long distance landlord is
tough business so I would try to get
something more local somewhere that you
can actually go check out whenever you
want to check in on the property and if
that means we're getting the spot you
know outside of the City by a half hour
45 minutes an hour so be it but I would
move at the speed of cash so Wendy when
is the right time to buy real estate
investment property when you have the
cash to do it however you can find a
deal
got it how old are you John
24. yeah my friend you're crushing it
you've already been able to put a
hundred thousand dollars in the bank
you're 24.
um now whether or not you choose to
believe George or not he's right
uh everybody tells you oh just use the
bank's money blah blah blah riches
Untold but here's the deal if you choose
to believe George and do it the right
way where you have no risk no stress
how much longer would it take you to get
200 000 more in the bank you're only 24.
it could be a multi-millionaire as a
result of waiting five or six years or
no expenses make no experiences just
keep stacking the cash my friend and
you're going to be way ahead of
everybody else I promise
wow that dude's impressive he's a hard
worker I like that really good stuff
George Campbell Ken Coleman with you
right now we're gonna go away for just a
few moments don't you go away this is
the Ramsey Show
[Music]
hey folks you know that sinking feeling
when you make an offer on a house you
love and then you hear there's another
offer you need the Churchill Mortgage
home buyer Edge super fast pre-approval
and a secured interest rate plus a five
thousand dollar seller guarantee gives
your offer the best chance of being
accepted the home buyer Edge from
Churchill gives you an advantage over
those other guys go to
churchillmortgage.com today to learn
more
[Music]
thank you
welcome back to the Ramsey Show I'm Ken
Coleman I'm joined by George Campbell
the phone number to jump in on the
conversation is triple eight eight two
five five two two five that's triple
eight eight two five five two two five
the question of the day is brought to
you by neighborly your hub for Home
Services neighborly has local service
providers to repair maintain and improve
your home I could put in there to keep
Ken married because I can't do anything
you know what I mean and so I need
resources like this their network of
experts offers top quality work and
customer service by train reliable
service providers find the help you need
at neighborly.com today today's question
comes from Alan in Ohio he writes I live
in an apartment but I'm looking to get a
home in the next year to year and a half
I work as a design engineer and
currently make 25 bucks an hour I've got
25 000 in student loan debt to the
government and I graduated in May of
2020. I want to know of any side hustles
that can help me pay off my student debt
it and help me build a comfortable life
for a future family thanks for the
question Alan I love this question right
and when you talk about somebody of
Allen's uh credibility or the word I'm
looking for is actually pedigree because
he goes to school and he gets an
engineering degree right and so
Engineers can command really good money
not just in salary but in freelance
hourly rates and the freelance economy
is what it's being labeled as right now
uh the gig economy is another term you
hear it's just fancy language for it's a
side hustle it's above and beyond my
full-time job and and professional White
Collar skilled jobs have more freelance
opportunity than ever before George
because of this weird economy we're in
where we have 10.1 million jobs
available but only 8 million people
unemployed so companies are also worried
about recession and so they've cut back
so instead of hiring a full-time
employee they're looking for contract a
contractor and you've done this work
before and in his situation where I
would start the Practical advice is his
top two or three skills is where he's
looking as an engineer and he's he's
separating those and he's going okay I'm
really good at this this and this and so
now he's looking out there where a
freelancing opportunities because he
brings credibility in that degree and
everyday experience and that's where
he's going to get the biggest bang for
the buck is actually his professional
skills now he can do other things we're
going to talk about in a minute for
everybody but you you've done this
out you actually did this and I wanted
you to share this because you made
really good money using your existing
professional skills yes so first of all
I was willing to do anything and so I
was driving for Uber and Lyft and doing
some of the normal early adopter on that
I got some sign-on bonuses when they
first came to Nashville when Uber and
Lyft wow so they gave me like a thousand
bucks to do like three rides it was
great so it was a great side money but
beyond that I went I don't like driving
strangers around it's not something I
enjoy can I find the side gig I enjoy
doing that I'm good at that's when I
went I've got marketing skills and I
found this post I did Ken back in uh
this is 2019 I was trying to save up for
our downloads is this from your personal
blog this is my personal blog my zanga
page here's what it says if you need
help with social media email marketing
branding copywriting content creation
website creation podcasting video audio
production production keynote
presentations DM me for Consulting work
and I got some great gigs helping small
business owners authors speakers build
websites and Squarespace I was making
1500 bucks a website 1500 bucks yeah and
were you using one of those uh the
website in a box Squarespace yeah that's
right so that was one I did marketing
Consulting back in when I was getting
rid of my Consumer Debt I think I made
23 Grand doing that part-time yeah
nights and weekends very doable all
right so let's let's also bring this
down to summer jobs for kids trying to
make money for college teachers too
people are trying to make extra money uh
we've got a an article that we did at
ramseysolutions.com we're not going to
go through all of these and I've got
some personal anecdotes stories here
what I'm seeing uh young people do that
can be done quite frankly by anybody uh
but you mentioned Uber and and Lyft
let's just say delivering food
delivering groceries delivering people
to places is still
a very very accessible opportunity uh
now I will say this it comes with wear
and tear on the car I've interviewed
some of these drivers and I think George
I've got to weigh it you got to weigh
that like okay the wear and tear
Insurance all that kind of stuff gas yes
make sure that you're covered contact
your auto insurance do not surprise them
if you get in a wreck while driving for
one of these apps you may not be covered
yeah don't say I didn't tell yourself uh
okay here we go here's some creative
things uh photographer uh tutoring uh in
in any type of uh topic there also
online teaching is an opportunity for a
lot of people the one that I love here
on the list and I'm seeing this is the
reselling people that are going to flea
market the flea market flipping that's
big you can really score uh and make
some really good money then you got to
know what you're doing yeah garage sales
yard sales flea markets even Goodwill
yeah buy stuff for cheap and look it up
on eBay see what it's selling for and go
clean it up and flip it uh the one that
I love sharing I share this on my Show
recently about a young lady who had just
graduated uh from law school and she was
looking to get on with a firm and uh
wasn't finding what she wanted she's
trying to figure it out and she stumbles
into uh someone who says I've got some
friends who want someone to walk their
dogs they've got three dogs and she says
well what do they pay and it's really
you know it's pretty good in New York
Manhattan oh okay that's big money there
so she starts doing it and she realized
like like this is really good money for
my time she now makes over a hundred
thirty thousand dollars a year in
Manhattan with a dog walking service to
where now she's got so many clients that
she Farms it out if you will to other
people but she's clearing over six
figures walking dogs that's amazing
which is well over 60 bucks an hour by
the way it's fantastic doing the math at
home all right here's a fun story George
uh my wife Stacy shared this story with
me of a young man in our neighborhood
right here in Franklin Tennessee who's
making several hundred dollars a week
are you ready for this yeah hit me power
washing this is a big one garbage cans a
power washer costs you can get them for
100 bucks yeah and so you got these
nasty stinking garbage cans I never even
thought about it and he's going around
he's power washed pressure washing these
uh garbage you can charge 15 20 bucks a
pop for these yeah and it takes you a
few minutes yeah here's another absurd
one and I say it's absurd that people
pay for this but folks we live in a
world where people have so much
disposable income all you got to do is
think about can I solve a problem now
this is absurd but this is my
neighborhood again this guy's 55 years
of age he's retired but he does this
just for fun and he's making a really
good he's making over five thousand
dollars a month you ready for this
picking up glass bottles what and
recycling them for people they just put
them out there they don't want to they
don't want to get rid of them they think
they should recycle but they don't want
to deal with it and he goes around and
picks them up and he's charging people
very handsomely because several hundred
homes where he's picking up I know where
you live Ken I may roll around that
neighborhood and here go some glass
who's throwing money out like that's wow
is that not absurd it's a great side
hustle I saw one in my neighborhood
painting mailboxes your mailbox gets a
little weathered a little worn we'll
repaint the mailbox so you can get so
creative and let me tell you dog walking
and pet sitting one of the most
lucrative things out there you can
charge 25 30 bucks an hour one of my
kids one of my kids is going to make a
thousand dollars over eight to ten days
dog sitting another golden doodle who
looks just like our dog Ellis you know
what I did the other day got my car my
house James he's looking at me like I'm
nuts I'm not kidding you it's 10 days
we're watching this dog thousand bucks
that's insane that's the market rate I
might do it you might maybe I'm open to
it but this is another one Ken mobile
car detailing show up in someone's
driveway big bucks use their water
spigot oh you clean their car I just I
paid a guy to do this last weekend he
did my car he did such a great job I
said come back tomorrow do my wife says
UV what'd you try I think it was a
hundred bucks
and maybe 125 for an SUV so in a few
hours he made 100 bucks another few
hours another 125 bucks and he can do
three four of these a day wow that's
some serious money yeah so get creative
and the more you're willing to put
effort in the more money you're gonna
make if you want to sit at home and take
little surveys on your phone you're not
going to make good money so so why do we
spend time on this
because there are a lot of people that
are constantly coming into our
atmosphere watching the show listening
to the show and they feel like getting a
thousand dollars in baby step one is
almost impossible the wages can that's
the problem and the fact is is folks
it's never been easier to make a
thousand dollars in quick time frames to
be able to get that baby step one funded
and then quite frankly keep that
momentum going and walk through baby
step two so you can do it it's very
important all kinds of options by the
way if you want to dive in deeper that
article
ramsaysolutions dot we're going to link
it in the show notes in the description
very nice thank you George for all the
podcasters it's 27 side hustle ideas
ramseysolutions.com all right we got to
pay some bills you know how important
that is and we'll be right back this is
the Ramsey Show
[Music]
foreign
[Applause]
[Music]
welcome back to the Ramsey show America
I'm Ken Coleman I'm joined by George
camel we're taking your calls this hour
it is toll-free triple eight eight two
five five two two five that's triple
eight eight two five five two two five
we have people who tune in to every
episode of the Ramsay show and they know
just about everything we teach about
money they can finish our sentences and
yet they're still feeling very stressed
out because they're stuck why is this
because knowing what to do with your
money isn't the issue it's doing what we
teach personal finance is 80 behavior
and only 20 head knowledge The Proven
way to change your behavior
with your money is by taking Financial
Peace University this class is the
difference between trying to get in
shape on your own versus hiring a
trainer you'll have a coordinator
holding you accountable and other people
in the class that are on the same
journey and they're pushing you with
their participation this is why the
classes work for millions of people
after nine weeks you'll handle money
like you never have before and you'll
never go back you'll make progress
faster than ever so don't just listen to
the show commit to joining
the progress the actual path
through financial Financial Peace and
University you can join at
ramseysolutions.com FPU that's
ramseysolutions.com FPU I'm teaching a
class right now George have you finished
your class mine starts June 20th so
people don't know this but for the first
time all the Ramsey personalities are
leading a class themselves virtually
kenz is already kicked off so you can't
join that one no too late too late for
party if you want to join me June 20th
we're going to be meeting around
lunchtime you can catch the replays this
one's fun I love that so that's an
option very good let's go to Beth in
Birmingham Alabama Beth how can we help
hello hi Beth what's up
well um I'm calling in with a question
uh I've been through a divorce
um and I have a five-year-old little
girl so I'm living with my parents
um my parents have been so so supportive
but I am feeling pressured just by my
own I guess expectations
um to move out into like around two
years I feel like that's a pretty good
goal but
um
I because of uh what I'm trying to save
um I'm nervous that
um I should rethink my dream of building
our house or I should rethink my time
frame so I was just curious what you
guys had to say about that I think you
set this up well
you know build it at all or adjust my
time frame to make it more realistic
what's what which way are you leaning
before you even asked us
um
well I guess
um I'm struggling with like my parents
have sat me down and then like are you
kidding like we want to be supportive
during this time like they're amazing
and there's such
they're incredible um but uh I just feel
guilty and I also feel like through all
of this in the divorce
um I
I I feel like I've failed
um in a lot of different ways but I feel
like
I just need to be able to show my little
girl
um I don't I just I guess I feel I'm
putting pressure on myself but I think
sometimes that's good
um as a parent you know I have
expectations for myself but I do I do
struggle with perfectionism are they
realistic expectations
um
I don't think they are right I don't
know well I don't think they are I think
you've got a timeline in your head that
you've pretty much have gotten to the
point where you realize this isn't
possible so I'm going to call Ken and
George and see if they think I should
abandon this dream of building my own
home yeah I don't like this either I
don't either pass fail if it's not done
in two years Beth has failed as a mom
you're an amazing mom I agree and having
a house or not will not change that and
your daughter seeing you build this
house or not doesn't change how she sees
you I would tell you point blank don't
abandon the dream because you can get
there now we're going to walk you
through the financial steps to do that
but there's no reason why you should
abandon the dream adjust the timeline
yes
and also Beth it's okay for drinks to
change yeah for a while I'm sorry I
would wait I would rent for a while
until you can afford it the right way
and we have very specific parameters to
help you do that and it's wait until you
have enough down payment to where you
can get a 15-year fixed rate mortgage
where the payments no more than a
quarter of your take-home pay
right and uh also you know this what was
this dream house you wanted is this like
a big house what were the the must-haves
why why build versus just buy a current
home
well um I've been looking at homes and
basically what I'm finding in my area is
like Meeks there's just uh everything's
just really expensive and then it's just
not at all what I want and I don't I and
I could be like I guess I'm a romantic
but part of me is just like I want to be
able to have this like I I just feel
like it would be something really
special to have From the Ashes of my
situation like like I because I've even
created it in Excel like the floor plans
and everything
um I know that's silly but
um no no hold on a second Beth so you've
interrupted yourself about three times
as you uh attempted to answer George
nobody puts my friend Beth down
especially not Beth I agree and and this
you this perfectionism that you just
admitted to that's what's going on and
it doesn't have to be perfect you're
gonna design your own home in Excel then
you're gonna get with an architect one
day when you're ready to to do this and
you've got the cash and the financial
situation to do it and you're going to
build a custom home I believe that if
you believe it but there's going to be a
season where we're building up to that
financially and if you've got to buy a
house in the meantime
and and pay that off uh or you put so
much down that you get great equity in
it as you continue to build then you
sell that and you turn that profit into
being able to put a huge amount down or
all cash on building a home this is very
very doable but but you've got to decide
what must be true in my financial life
then what must be true in my personal
life to be able to get to that Financial
place and then we just walk that out and
then the time will take care of itself
right George yeah so Beth walk us
through some numbers here do you have
any debt
I
I fully um I've gone I haven't gone
through like officially financial piece
but I've had like I've gone through the
steps um so I have no debt when I uh
with served papers
um for divorce I had four thousand and
now I have twenty thousand dollars in my
emergency fund so that's a fully funded
emergency fund and so now I have nine
and I and I also was a stay-at-home mom
so like God has given me the opportunity
to have a job and I'm I'm making it's
more than I have ever made it's 60 a
year so that's a big deal for me
um but so I've got 9 000 for my um house
down payment savings so that's wonderful
no debt fully funded emergency fund
you're you've got a nine thousand dollar
Head Start so now we need to look at
what is our our savings goal is it a
hundred thousand we need to get some
real numbers on what this would cost to
build this custom home or work with a
home builder an existing neighborhood
that can give you what you want have you
looked into that
well
and I've talked with a builder which he
just goes to my church so it's nothing
formal but it's a hundred and he said
that it's going about 180 per square
foot and so the house that I've planned
or whatever sketched whatever is um like
about 1800 square feet so it would be
like
300 something 325 plus you need to land
yes okay so with my take on pay like I'm
only going to be able to afford about
1200 a month I think okay
and so then we need to go with this
maybe a six-year dream instead of a
two-year dream which means I can't live
you know with Mom and Dad for the next
six years let's have a strategy to where
we move out in a year or two we rent for
a while we get the income up and we
continue to save up that down payment
until we can have that dream home or we
compromise and go I really want to get
in a home faster than that I'm going to
get a 200 000 home town home in my area
until I can get there so you have a lot
of options but I don't want it to be
either I build this home in two years
from a failure and I'll never accomplish
what I set out to accomplish
right and this home will not fill any
void and so I don't want you to have the
illusion that going through this is
going to change that I want you to deal
with the past hurt and grieve what you
lost and now create a new picture of
what's to come that's what our friend Dr
John deloney would say yeah and Beth
listen your hero to your to your
daughter I mean this is this is this is
about the future and the best for you is
still yet to be you've got this you got
to believe it and be okay waiting for it
while we work for it that's the hardest
part thank you so much Beth we're
cheering you on thanks to George
Campbell for a great hour I want to
thank James Childs our fearless leader
behind the glass and the entire crew to
keep us on the air I want to thank you
America for listening this is the Ramsay
show
foreign
[Music]
hey George camel here if you love the
show and you want a deeper dive on your
money Journey we've got a Weekly
Newsletter that gives you helpful
articles and tips on following the
Ramsay way just go to
ramseysolutions.com today to sign up for
the newsletter again that's
ramseysolutions.com to sign up for our
Weekly Newsletter
[Music]
live from the headquarters of Ramsey
Solutions broadcasting from the PODS
moving and storage Studio this is the
Ramsey Show it's where we help you win
with your money your work and your
relationships I'm Ken Coleman joined by
my colleague George Campbell the phone
number to jump in is toll-free it's
triple eight eight two five five two two
five that's triple eight eight two five
five two two five let's go to San Diego
California I love that City George
beautiful one of the many reasons no
bugs
I didn't think about it no bugs we live
in the south where mosquitoes can carry
a toddler I don't go outside unless I
have to yeah not in San Diego my friend
uh all right so Lena Ray is there let's
go how can we help
Lena Ray
hello Hi how are you guys we're great
what's going on
so I'm in a dilemma because I'm in the
military and I'm transferring out within
the next about a year I'd say 12 months
uh uh 12 months and 14 months from now
um but I'm in the baby steps I'm
currently in baby step number two and
I'm thinking about selling my car
um I just don't know how to go about
that what I'm just afraid I guess to
take the next step and choose a car what
how much loan should I take no all right
so first and foremost we want to say
thank you for serving our country you
are a great American thank you very much
for that tell us about this car that
you're thinking about selling
Tesla you're talking to the right guy
today with George George likes Tesla's
there's no such thing
I'm sorry to break it to you the best
interest rate is zero percent with a
zero dollar payment that's what I got in
my test so now why do you want to sell
this Tesla why why are you calling us
asking us uh about selling this
are you is it killing you is the car
payment killing you let's be honest
absolutely and you're not even driving
it much
I'm not driving it much no okay and
what's it worth
um after plugging in the numbers at a
higher value Maybe
to 39 right now
let's say you sold it for 40. that
leaves you with no money to buy a card
do you have any cash on hand
just by uh one thousand
saved okay
and no other debt
no I actually do have a lot more debt
and that's why I'm trying to sell it
okay so this is one step 75 with the car
what's the other debt
it's all Consumer Debt on credit cards
okay oh so you got 35 000 in credit card
debt
yep what's the interest rate on that
uh the highest interest rate on one of
the cards is 27 correct oh I need some
peps at AC oh okay Harper I'm almost
done paying that one off good well
absolutely we are selling this car are
you gonna need a car ASAP to get around
yes okay so can we get you a little
beater car let's say you waited to sell
this Tesla for three months and whatever
you have saved in three months we're
gonna find you a cheap car is that
reasonable
yeah what's your income
um total income I would say 9 000 after
taxes a month
yes and how much of that do you have
after paying your minimum payments on
your debts how much could you save
towards that beater car
I'm only paying minimum I
thousand dollars
okay oh boy oh boy all right I'm on the
hunt San Diego used car six thousand
dollars
the exact opposite of what you're
driving now what model Tesla is this
a model y okay
all right so you're gonna miss that
Tesla and whatever's next is going to be
the saddest worst thing you've ever
driven for now the good news is we're
gonna get you back in a Tesla if that's
what you so choose later on down the
line once we are debt free with a fully
funded emergency fund and we're gonna do
it with no payments we're gonna pay cash
sound good
okay I'm glad you're willing to make the
sacrifice most people calling in are
even unwilling to sell the car so the
fact that you're going should I sell it
I feel like I need to and you have a
great income you're making six figures
yeah so we're going to knock out the
rest of this credit card debt real fast
without that payment what's that Tesla
payment right now
almost 900 bucks back in your life to
throw with this credit card debt 837 a
game changer oh my gosh because you're
probably paying 800 bucks in interest on
those credit cards right now at least
oh
Lena Ray we are pulling for you to knock
out this debt fast is there any way you
can create more income
yeah so I'm actually I've been doing
door Dash and I did it for one weekend
just to try it out and only did maybe
like 14 hours and made 400 bucks that's
awesome whoa that's incredible the good
news about doordash is no one gives a
rip what you drive that's true they just
cared their food got there and it's
still warm isn't that different and if
you're that embarrassed by it I'm a fan
of just pulling 500 yards down the
street they don't see it that's true
nobody cares to your point sure good for
you well that's awesome Lena Ray drive
like no one else until later on you can
drive like no one else you're doing it
the right way well said proud of you and
again thank you for your service you are
a great American and you've got this
let's go to Lincoln Nebraska where
Jackson is on the line Jackson how can
we help
hey hey how are you guys doing we're
having a blast what's going on
awesome awesome okay so me and my wife
are out of baby step two we have baby
step three done uh we were gonna save
for a house
um but I really really want to be a
pilot uh as my long-term career
eventually and if we go that route we
would be putting off buying a house for
several years because flight school is
quite pricey and it takes a while so I
just want to know what would you guys do
I would do whatever it takes to get
through the pilot training without any
debt at all and if that means putting
off multiple things that's what I would
do
because there's just there's no reason
to have any debt for this it is
expensive but when you come out of this
thing you're gonna be one of the few
pilots who have no debt and you're gonna
be flying the friendly Skies debt free
and the house will still be there so I I
would do whatever it takes not to go
into debt cash flow how long would that
take to save up in cash flow this
so it's about
um it's 95 000 for all seven ratings and
um then I have to be an instructor to
build my hours for for a couple years so
I'd say it would probably take about
three years to save up and then probably
another two or three years to go through
everything because it while doing a
full-time job here
um it would be hard to
um go faster than that so get through
the get through the training and
everything and then I'd have to be a
flight instructor for maybe a couple
years so I'm looking at I mean it's it's
a long journey going to med school it is
and you have a spouse
yes what do they think
yeah they're they're very supportive
she's very supportive of me
um she wants a house I mean we've kind
of talk like hey we can rent a house
eventually I mean like if we want to
have more space we can still rent in the
future and she's okay with that and
she's completely on board as well well
that's huge that's the most important
part yeah because then you're going to
be willing to do whatever it takes
because we agreed on this vision for our
life and it may take longer it may look
different but I love that you're
choosing your reality and we can't have
the cake and eat it too we want the
house we want to do the pile but we've
got to choose which one is the priority
and here's the thing Jackson I'm not
saying you're gonna do this but it could
be very easy for someone in your
situation on a long journey like this to
start to feel guilty about Midway
through and your wife is still
supportive she's on board for the vision
but all of a sudden you go oh I feel
like we gotta get a house and we we just
slip into debt don't do it stay the
course it's gonna work out don't move
more of your calls coming up this is the
Ramsey Show
thank you
[Music]
if you're like most people your home is
your most valuable asset and when you
want to make improvements it can feel
like everything costs too much or takes
too long but something as simple as
custom window coverings from blinds.com
can completely change your space and add
value to your home we've recommended
blinds.com for over a decade so you know
you can trust them from blinds drapes
and shutters to motorized Shades they
make it easy and affordable to upgrade
your entire home and their team is ready
to help with everything from design
consultation to measuring and
installation plus there are never any
misleading quotes or hidden fees ever
backed by their 100 percent satisfaction
guarantee and shipping is always free
see whyblinds.com is the number one
online retailer of custom window
coverings go to blinds.com now and save
40 off selected products visit
blinds.com today for more info
[Music]
foreign
welcome back to the Ramsey show America
I'm Ken Coleman I'm joined by my
colleague George camel we're here for
you this hour as we answer your
questions about money about your work
and about your relationships all three
of those
areas of your life they just have a way
George of bleeding into each other if
you're not winning in one it tends to
affect the other and we are here for you
this hour triple eight eight two five
five two two five that's triple eight
eight two five five two two five let's
go to Megan who joins us in Atlanta
Georgia Megan how can we help
hi um thank you so much for taking my
call
um I just I'm a recent
um graduate I just got my Master's
Degree and I'll be working for the first
time
um pretty soon and I just wanted to
um know how to go about establishing
Financial boundaries with my parents no
oh
so the very question here George tells
me that you feel like there aren't some
healthy boundaries now they're Crossing
I'm just curious what what is the source
of this what are you concerned about as
maybe not being a boundary what's going
on tell us a little bit more
um so I had the gracious just pleasure
my last year of grad school living with
a family member and
um they didn't charge me at all and they
even opened up saying like hey we get
you're just starting out you know like
you can stay with us longer I definitely
had planned on you know giving like a
monetary gift of monthly even though
it's not required however my dad is kind
of like very just expectant of like how
much are you gonna give and I kind of
was like oh I think that's for me and
that family member to discuss and so
he's not involved in this in the actual
transaction it's not his place yeah he's
not has he's just gone well you should
be paying them
insistent on knowing how much I would be
paying them and like creating like that
number for me instead of me and that
family member
and what is your response been to him
when he's uh digging
uh I I told him you know that I'll talk
to it with the family member and he
definitely wasn't happy about it um he
said you know I as as my father I
shouldn't keep information like that I'm
being secretive so I I just want to go
about like you know I do love my dad and
everything but I do think it's time for
me as an adult like you know be on my
own and so just trying to find that
short balance all right so let me let me
ask a question
is it that you don't want to pay the
amount that he's suggesting or you just
don't want his his input at all and the
reason I ask that is because what's the
big deal with you just going dad here's
what I've decided I'm happy to tell you
it's not a secret I'm just deciding what
I'm giving and
it feels like he just wants to have
input and I'm just wondering why is it
that big of a deal for you to just say
to him all right this is what I'm paying
dad you want to know what I'm going to
do this is what we've arranged and then
if he disagrees then you deal with it
so my dad
um
his input
he'll say it's you know a suggestion but
there's an implicit thing that you kind
of have to do it okay so this to you is
a clear dividing line by saying I'm not
even going to tell you it's just between
me and this other family yeah so what is
his motivation you know him better than
anyone what do you think's behind this
I know his motivation
um is definitely just like
I know his motivation is definitely just
to I guess make sure that family members
aren't talking and thinking I'm just
mooching it's his reputation on the line
yeah essentially oh okay that's what I
was digging for yep because the motive
matters some parents are just going you
know they have they looking out for you
they want the best for you but this
feels like if they find out through the
grapevine of the family that she's only
paying 300 bucks they're gonna be coming
at me going wow your daughter's so cheap
and that's a reflection
yeah okay well uh this is as our friend
Dr Henry Cloud would say you've got to
draw the boundary line
the property line that marks what you're
responsible for and what he's
responsible for and this is not his
responsibility
yeah if it's going to put a tear in the
relationship that's on him not on you
and I know that's hard to say
but it's going to it may cause a riff
that is unrepairable depending on his
response do you think it's do you think
it's not uh you think it's something
that's going to last a long time or do
you think he's going to get over it
eventually
um I'm hoping and praying it doesn't
last a long time
um you know I definitely told my parents
that I've been thankful for everything
but I do think just me as an adult going
forward these are just some things I
should kind of like keep to myself
regarding my finances so this
conversation has already happened yeah
yeah and how is it so far
what was his reaction
and he wasn't happy yeah but I
understand he wasn't happy I want to
know what was his reaction like when you
say not happy did I mean he was gave you
the silent treatment did it mean no he
he definitely you know definitely blew
up which is expected
um I'm sorry definitely did the whole
like you know as your father which is
expected
um my mom was also not the happiest but
she's more understanding like you know
I'm not happy but I understand it's what
you have to do
um how long ago was this
like a couple hours oh okay fresh so
this is like the hot now sign at Krispy
Kreme Donuts I mean this is this is
fresh yeah
um
well
do you believe you did the right thing
yes or no
I do okay I do
parents are the best at making us feel
guilty and selfish our decisions yeah I
think you have to hold the line to say I
love you too I respect you I'm sorry you
feel the way that you feel but I'm still
your girl your values are intact I'm
doing the right thing and cast a vision
on what this is going to look like going
forward and so that they get their mind
off of this fear that George pulled up
on here I mean he figured your dad out
pretty quick on this deal and so it's
this is some selfishness going on here
but it's what I would call uh it's
unintentional your dad's just worried
about you his reputation the whole nine
yards and you know what he's having a
hard time letting go
of you
yeah so I would tell you to and I feel
like you have the spirit on you right
now but the spirit of Grace of
understanding compassion for Dad which
is hard to have compassion for somebody
that blows up on you
yeah
and I'm going to do you one better Megan
we're actually going to send you a copy
of our friend Dr Henry Cloud's book
boundary so hang on the line and I will
make sure you're sent that book and it
may be one you you give to Dad not
passive aggressively but you're saying
dad this book's been really helpful for
me I'm learning all this now as I'm
becoming an adult I've had to have these
really hard conversations I found it
helpful not just for this but for all
areas of life and I think you'd get a
lot of value out of it too I think
you're right Ken dad's having a hard
time letting go he's used to being able
to tell the daughter what to do she's a
grown woman now she gets to make her own
decisions yeah and based on what I heard
from her she's very respectful I think
so too she's got her life together she's
not doing anything out of control yeah
you know what it makes me think of
I was reading and I'm sure you've seen
these lists before they're quite popular
in fact there was a best-selling book
written by a Australian nurse uh that
she was a hospice nurse and she
published this book on the the top
regrets of people who are dying oh and
one of the top five regrets of people
who are dying is I wish I had lived the
life that was true to what I wanted to
live
in other words and as you start to
unpack that phrase
you realize that these were people who
made big decisions in life
that pleased others based on the
expectation that did not please
themselves and so what happens is if you
don't establish boundaries here and
you're always trying to make decisions
that please others that are in absolute
a conflict with what you believe you
should do you are going to be a person
who dies with regret
and it's that important yeah well I've
heard this quote and Dr John alone is
quoting another psychologist physician
when he says choose guilt over
resentment yeah right that's the
healthiest way to go about your life
resentment will eat you alive guilt is
something we go yeah okay yeah so feel
guilty for telling Dad off but at least
I'm not resentful so true I'd rather
disappoint somebody than and resent than
live an inauthentic life isn't that true
man
wow well Megan uh we got the book coming
for you you read it and live it it's
really it's going to be a game changer
and set you free thank you so much for
the call all right folks quick
commercial break more of the Ramsey show
coming up don't move
[Music]
y'all there's a lot you can't control
when it comes to health care but there
is something you should check out that
can help Christian Healthcare Ministries
chm is not Insurance it is budget
friendly biblically based Health cost
sharing that means a community of
members helping share the burden of each
other's health care costs they help
people just like you in all 50 states so
see if chm could be right for your
family learn more today at
chministries.org budget
[Music]
thank you
welcome back America you are joining the
conversation here on the Ramsey Show I'm
Ken Coleman I'm joined by George camel
the phone number to jump in is triple
eight eight two five five two two five
you got a work question not happy but
you're freaking out I'm in the baby
steps can I can I interrupt my income do
I need to uh you got a money question
well we are here for you triple eight
eight two five five two two five a lot
of you are planning to move sometime
soon and that's always exciting uh but
we've got to get real with you here in
most places around the country you're
going to be facing some sky-high home
prices interest rates are not going to
return to the record lows anytime soon
but that doesn't make it impossible to
own a home if you want to buy or sell
you got to make sure that you're
financially ready and that you've got a
trusted and experienced real estate
agent to walk you through it not Uncle
Larry who just got his license last
month you need a pro who's a true expert
you can find a high caliber Ramsay
trusted agent like that through our
endorsed local providers program
and we vet the agents around the country
so you're going to get the best support
whether you're moving from Florida to
Alaska or buying your first home
somewhere in between go to
ramseysolutions.com agent that's
ramseysolutions.com
agent let's go to Atlanta Georgia Sarah
is on the line Sarah how can we help
hi there here's my question
I am 54 years old and I just got out of
debt I am a substitute teacher who is
building her emergency fund as we speak
is it impractical for me to dream about
owning a building at my age that would
house my own LLC restaurant
okay and how old are you you broke up
when you told us
maybe that's God
there's no shame in your game but it
does play into our answer how old
54. okay 54. got it and what is your
current income
um well it's um I make um
1000 roughly one thousand seven hundred
dollars a month and how often are you
substitute teaching to make that
about 14 days roughly a month okay and
what about the other you know 16 or so
days in the month are you working
uh I
I mean it varies uh okay it's not right
14 but it just depends on it I'm
classified as on call so it just depends
on when they need me that kind of thing
okay well my the reason I ask is to
figure out how we can get you closer to
your goal and income is a huge part of
that you know we always we always say
that your greatest wealth building tool
is your income and and Ken is so good at
helping people increase that which is a
huge part of getting to this goal you
said you're in baby step three you're
getting the emergency fund in place
that's great do you have anything in
retirement
no okay
so so okay so so
it's going to take we've got to stop
looking at time and I understand in the
heart of your question but you at the
situation the time will take care of
itself the answer to your original
question is it realistic for me at 54 to
think about owning a building that I
could then have a restaurant in
it's realistic yes based on activity and
your income and right now you are you
are not making much money at all and so
the clock is ticking really fast for you
and so the more income you can make then
we get more realistic on what that time
frame looks like but I lived in the
Atlanta Georgia area for a long time
what area do you live in
I live on the South Side live on the
South Side okay so uh have you even
looked at a building that uh would would
house what you want to do with it and
you have any idea what that would cost
in your area
yes I had looked at that okay what are
we looking at cost wise
uh 178 000 okay see now we've got a
number and so how long will it take us
to save up 178 thousand dollars
because we don't want you going into
debt for this building okay because
you're you're really you really are at
this stage of the game you don't have
much retirement at all you're working
through baby step three which is great
so this is gonna have to be a get after
it hustle situation and so if the
numbers five years seven years ten years
that number is determined by the income
that you can make
do you understand what I'm saying
yes sir and then we have and did I hear
you say restaurant that you wanted to
have a restaurant as well in this
building
yes I want to own the building and um
move my LLC restaurant in I've already
got my LLC status for my restaurant but
um I just um need a building
we're currently running this from yeah
where are you running I don't want to
rent
because it's like seven or eight
thousand dollars a month and and I want
to put that money toward my humanitarian
efforts because I have a humanitarian
Edge
to my LLC restaurant are you running a
restaurant right now
no we're just on we exist on paper
that's it okay that's what I thought so
it's an LLC but it's not a restaurant uh
Georgia I mean we got it we got a
decision I want to be realistic yeah
based on your income right now this
stream is not going to it's not gonna
happen based on your income right now we
would need to increase this by a whole
lot and I want to think about where how
do how does Sarah retire one day let's
just say the restaurant doesn't happen
we need a game plan yep
so we need to figure out how do we start
investing do you have a home currently
yes is it paid for
yes it is paid off okay what's the home
worth
Melissa what what is the home worth
um it's worth 80 000. okay and that's
pretty much all you have to your name
plus your emergency fund okay yes so I
want you to start thinking about
developing a plan so that 10 years from
now 64 we've developed a little bit of a
nest egg by investing that may start
with a Roth IRA for you maxing that out
but we also need to get our income up to
do that right now we don't have money to
invest we don't have money to save
towards this restaurant and we're not
gonna be able to buy a building in cash
so it may start with I'm gonna go work
at a restaurant learn the ins and outs
of the business get in with the manager
maybe take over management one day so
that when the time comes I'm ready to do
this thing
okay would you be willing to do that to
go work at a restaurant and learn all
the ins and outs of the business
uh I would be willing to
um start from the ground up I I have a
college degree so so okay I'll be able
to so Sarah here's what I'm jumping in
real quick so we've got to start to get
some real numbers for you to see
we got to get out of our head and we've
got to get some real numbers so you've
got to increase your income to the level
that as George is saying that you
actually can put 15 of your income away
in baby step four because that's first
and foremost it's more important than
the restaurant
and then after that in a given year
you're going to have to be able to put
20 to 30 000 away a year George on
minimum yeah just to get to the point
where we can buy 178 180 000 building
plus any startup cost and I'm concerned
about the startup cost of the restaurant
there's a question and truthfully the
rate at which restaurants fail is scary
it's normal so I want you to do so much
research too so much homework talk to
actual restaurant owners whether they've
been successful or unsuccessful learn
from these people before you jump in
because I'm worried at this point we're
never going to be able to retire yeah
and uh that's my biggest biggest concern
for you right I agree and so Sarah this
is not in any way meant to dash the
dream I just want you to have a
realistic picture of what you're dealing
with you're looking at on the low end 20
to 30 000 a year that you'd have to save
you start multiplying that at 54 how
many years we're talking about and
that's going to be a very sobering
picture but a picture you need to see
yeah okay and here's why
you could buy a building and may never
launch a restaurant in it but if you buy
the building down the line and it
becomes a part of your retirement
strategy or maybe you get involved in a
restaurant and work your way up into
management and get involved and maybe
buy Equity into I mean the point is is
that why are you dreaming about a
restaurant you're not going to make you
answer that but we may have to adjust
the details of the dream but keep the
essence of the dream because of the
financial realities George that's that's
that's where we sit and so if we can't
do this what can we do that meets that
same heartfelt desire that she thinks
the restaurant this LLC and I I'm always
a fan of starting small and doing it
with cash that may mean eventually maybe
one day we have a food truck and maybe
one day that food truck becomes so
successful we have the brick and mortar
store I love them and one day we get so
successful with that we buy the building
and we that's the stair stepping I want
here yeah that's really good advice
Sarah thank you so much for the call do
the homework get a real pick picture of
what you're dealing with and now you've
got a plan that you can attack thank you
again for the call he's George Campbell
I'm Ken Coleman this is the Ramsey Show
we'll be right back
[Music]
[Applause]
foreign
[Music]
thank you
welcome back to the Ramsey Show I'm Ken
Coleman joined by George camel triple
eight eight two five five two two five
is the phone number to jump in today's
scripture of the day is proverbs 4 25
and 26 let your eyes look directly ahead
and let your gaze be fixed straight in
front of you watch the path of your feet
in all your ways will be established our
quote of the day George you must have
picked this one I know you're a big Shaq
I had nothing to do with it but I'm a
fan I'd love to see you in Shaq side by
side in a picture we've seen Mugsy
Bogues out there that's pretty much what
you're gonna get you like that it's
about the same thing I love that today's
quote from Shaquille O'Neal Excellence
is not a singular act but I have it you
are what you repeatedly do
I don't know do you think Shaq said that
it feels like we could have put anyone's
name there and I would have believed it
so it's plausible Shaq's funny I love
Shaq he is a uh he had a podcast for a
while and he's got he's got some great
quotes I just don't see him saying it
that way that one feels too serious it
is he's he's a great dude though very
funny guy I had a chance to meet him
once and he swapped when he shook my
hand it was like my entire arm went into
his hand it was like a baseball mitt
yeah essentially wow fantastic triple
eight eight two five five two two five
is the number Providence Rhode Island is
where we go next Jaden is there Jaden
how do we help
how's it going good what's going on
uh yeah so just uh shortly briefly uh
summarize my my situation I'm uh 21
years old
I uh when I graduated high school
originally I went and took a year and a
half of college
and um my major kind of just I kind of
lost interest covered was happening I
was online so I gained some student uh
student loans and um from there I
switched careers and I went into the
iron workers so I'm in that union now
and I have about 9.2 just about 9 200 of
debt right now
and uh that's counting uh 500 of credit
from my credit card I'm just honestly
looking for the best way or some some
Financial advice to go from here because
I'm doing monthly payments currently but
I feel like it's like it's just going
nowhere
Okay so we've got about 8 700 in student
loans 500 on credit cards yes are those
separate student loans how many are
there if you broke them out uh there's
four separate student loans what's the
smallest one
the smallest one's fifteen hundred cool
so the this is the way I attacked my
student loan debt I it was exactly like
you I had credit card debt student loan
debt back in 2013. I had 40 grand total
and so the way I attacked it was using a
method called the debt snowball method
where we lay these debts out from
smallest to largest so your credit card
goes first how quickly if you made
minimum payments on your student loans
how quickly could you attack the credit
card debt if you were working extra
selling stuff on a budget cutting
expenses
um I mean right now the job I'm working
on I'm making if I work a 40 hour week
I'm taking home about 650 a week okay
so um I mean I have some other bills
monthly but
like such as a car insurance and whatnot
I mean I could I feel as if I could
definitely pay it off in like a month or
two yeah I was gonna say like a month
and a half two months if I just
completely focus on it great so then you
free up that credit card payment and now
we can apply that plus all the extra
margin you had to the next payment and
the next payment until you knock all of
your debts out smallest to largest and
on average that takes folks 18 to 24
months well you know with uh with your
level of debt nine grand I think you'll
do it faster
okay
sounds good so that's the way to do it
my man that's it it's that simple and
it's that hard because you gotta focus
on one thing at a time and you have to
not look at the interest rates which is
hard to do and you just have to go on a
Vengeance yeah Focus yeah great Linda is
up next in Austin Texas Linda how can we
help
hey thanks for taking
I have
congratulations
excited yes you should be 72.
say that again
I've been working since 1972.
that's fantastic how long have you been
retired Linda
well I'm it's uh next Saturday is my
last day is the retirement the second
time around I retired once in California
and I moved to Austin and got a job
again and been working and here I am I'm
doing a little Encore career and now we
were sailing off no she's done she's
she's had it folks she's out plus you
get two retirement parties I like that
yeah good okay so what's your question I
have been collecting uh social security
for a couple years and I get a pension
from California which I'm doing pretty
good you know monthly I have no bills
but one thing came up here at this time
my mom passed away a couple years ago
so I'm going to get about
000 and I owe 83 000 on my house and I
have a interest rate of 2.875
so my question is the financial advisor
which I just rolled over my 401k for
that company at 103 000 I rolled it over
this week she says I shouldn't pay my
house off of that money I should just
reinvest it with them because the
interest rate well of course Linda the
financial advisor is going to tell you
to invest with them ah it's like asking
again it would be like asking a
gastroenterologist if if you want to get
a colonoscopy you know it's you're gonna
you're going to the wrong place for
advice on debt payoff wow yeah I know I
know you were going to say that but so
not that they're a bad financial advisor
but their incentivized to get you to
invest that's how they make money that's
how their brain thinks so I would
encourage you to pay off this mortgage
tomorrow
you're going to get a payoff quote and
wire the money yeah and you'll still
have 31 grand left
yeah so then what do I do with that
with that well so what was your mortgage
payment
uh my mortgage payment was without taxes
616 Okay so we've got a few extra 100
bucks in the uh in the budget now we
have our social security we have our
pension about
4240 between Social Security and my
pension awesome skills well now we just
got a little cushion in retirement and
now we can live and give like no one
else we can give a little more spend a
little more and continue to invest do
you have any other Investments
no I just rolled that over this week to
an investor and they're going to put in
some mutual funds okay I've never done
that before so but you have no money in
Investments it's all Social Security and
pension right now until we get this
money
yeah well that money is rolled over yeah
it's here already I just got to take it
down there and give them a check next
week yeah whatever's left throw into
some mutual funds and you can continue
to pile on top of that with whatever
margin you have left but I like having a
goal for giving saving and spending and
so let's increase our giving a little
bit let's have Linda have a little fun
uh increase some of the spending line
items for fun money and then we're going
to invest some as well
okay so then I guess I could uh give it
to them or else I was just going to put
it in a CD account or just to have for
in case something happens I don't know
yeah I would just park in a high yield
savings account and keep it liquid uh
that way if an opportunity strikes or do
you want to buy something or whatever it
is you'll have that money ready to go
and you've got you've got great rates
right now with those high yield savings
accounts yes I've been looking at them
the CD rates and all that put in there
for a while so
um I really appreciate you so I'm glad
I'm gonna go pay my house off next week
on my retirement Linda that's amazing it
is that is so fantastic to be retired
and no house payment and that's a nice
little chunk of change you get to decide
what to do with and George gave you some
great advice so these are the fun
problems we get to Grapple with yeah is
Linda out there
yes Linda what is one fun thing that you
think you'd like to do now with this
extra margin
what is it one thing no no one no no one
fun thing I don't want to put pressure
on you and say one thing but what's one
fun thing George gave you some great
advice celebrating this Milestone two
Milestones what do you think you want to
do
oh God I don't know
go on a vacation somewhere there we go
where are you going
what's on the list Paris France or
something Paris the City of Lights be
fantastic
yes all right all expenses paid no no
debt here we're not going back you need
to stay in tune with George and
everything he's doing this guy can give
you all kinds of hacks on how to do
Paris for Less that's true have you done
a video yet on this I need to you
probably should I was looking at Costco
Travel at Paris trips see I got the itch
Ken there you go Linda Costco Travel
this is more than you asked for today
it's more than America needed Costco
card there's a Costco pot too they're
not hey Costco member you're you're I'm
a fan of that as long as not the credit
card cut up the credit card but if it's
a membership card oh no I don't use I
just use a debit card no she just means
to get in the building George you never
know these days Ken okay I guess she's
good hey Linda's going to Paris I think
we just Center like price is right
you're going to Paris I know but I had
nothing to do for three hey good hour
George always fun to be with you my
friend I want to thank the James Childs
our fearless leader and the entire crew
behind the glass for keeping us on the
air hey America this is your show thank
you for tuning in we believe in you you
got this this is the rain show
[Music]
thank you
hey it's Ken if you like what you heard
in this episode and want to know more
about getting started on the Ramsey Baby
Steps go to ramsesolutions.com and click
on the get started button we'll help you
figure out the best next step for you
based on your specific situation again
that's ramseysolutions.com and click get
started
[Music]